-We're hanging out
with Hailee Steinfeld!
Now, Hailee and I are about
to play a singing version of
"The Whisper Challenge."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Voices whispering ]
-"Whisper Challenge."
-Now, here's how it works.
One person will put
on these headphones,
noise-canceling,
with loud music playing,
then the other person
picks up a card.
Here's your cards,
and these are mine.
-Don't look.
-Sorry. I'm not looking.
And then you sing the song
lyrics on your card,
and the person
wearing the headphones
tries to guess
what they're singing.
-Okay. Question.
-Yes?
-Where does
the whispering happen?
[ Laughter ]
Can you whisper --
-It feels like a whisper
if you're the person
that can't hear.
-Oh. Got it.
Hey. That's where it is. Okay.
-Yeah. Sure, sure, sure. Okay.
Now...
-I'm going to whisper my songs.
-You can whisper the songs.
Yeah, go for it.
I won't know the difference.
-Yeah, I know you won't.
-Hailee -- Or maybe
I'll whisper mine, and you
wouldn't know the difference.
That's the fun part of the game.
-Listen.
-Pinky pound.
-Eee!
-All right.
Now, Hailee,
put on these headphones.
I'm going to go first.
-Oh, no.
-I will sing you a song lyric,
and you'll guess
what I'm singing.
-All right.
-Okay?
Let me turn it on for you.
-Yeah.
[ Loud music playing ]
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Oh, damn.
You know what I'm saying?
That's right.
-Okay.
-All right.
Okay.
[ Humming softly ]
♪ Maybe we found love
right where we are ♪
-Baby, we found -- Wait.
This is really loud!
-I know, I know.
Here we go. Ready?
-I get why it's called
the "Whisper." Okay.
-♪ Maybe ♪
-Baby, we...
-Found.
-Love.
-Love in a hopeless place.
No? Baby, we found...
-Close. We found love.
-Love.
-Right.
-We -- Right hand. Right here.
"Right where we are."
-Yes.
-[ Ding ]
-That's it.
Check that out.
-What?!
-You got it. You got it right.
-Maybe we found love
right where we are?
-And then it was also,
"Now that we found love,
what are we gonna do with it?"
♪ Now that ♪
There we go. All right.
-Okay. My turn.
-Yeah.
-[Whispering]
I'm going to whisper it.
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm gonna swing ♪
-Um...you're sweet.
-♪ From a chandelier ♪
-Uh, do you want some drinks?
-[Normal voice]
♪ I'm gonna swing ♪
-Hey, I'm putting the tray.
-♪ From the chandelier ♪
-The tray? No.
♪ I'm gonna swing ♪
-Sway.
-Swing. Swing.
-I'm gonna swing.
-I'm -- Sway.
-From the chandelier.
-I swear -- I swear to God.
-I'm gonna swi--
-If you -- I sway.
-I'm gonna swing.
-I sweet. I sway into you.
-Swing. Like on a swing.
-I sway into you.
-I'm gonna swing.
-I'm swaying with you.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna swing.
-I'm gonna sway.
-Swing!
-I'm gonna swing!
-Swing! Chandelier!
-Oh! Chandelier!
-Yes.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course. Sorry, sorry.
I forgot. I forgot that lyric.
Were you whispering or singing?
-I whispered,
and then I was shouting.
-Okay, all right, here we go.
-Okay.
-All right.
I really don't like this song.
I loathe this song.
Out of all the songs,
I really dislike this one.
Ready?
-I'm ready.
-♪ Santa Baby ♪
-Death baby?
-♪ Hurry down
the chimney tonight ♪
-Everything -- What?
-♪ Santa Baby ♪
-Death baby. Music.
-♪ Put the sable
under the tree ♪
-With a la-- With a drink.
-No.
♪ Santa Baby ♪
-What is this?
Give me something.
-That is something.
All right, ready?
Ho, ho, ho.
-Christmas. Santa.
-"Santa Baby."
-"Santa Baby!"
-Yes.
So. Hurry, hurry.
-Running. Running.
-Hurry down the chimney.
-Down the chimney.
Santa Baby...
-Hurry down...
-Something down
the chimney tonight.
-That's correct. There you go.
-[ Dinging ]
-That's it.
-This is so crazy.
-I was saying
I don't enjoy that song.
-"Hurry" down the chimney.
-Yeah, yeah.
I don't enjoy that song.
-"Hurry." I got you.
-♪ Santa Cutie ♪
♪ I wanna ring and a... ♪
Ugh. Come on.
What is happening?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Hold on. Here we go.
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh,
hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm ♪
♪ I like to move it, move it ♪
I like to move it, move it,
unh ♪
-Ready, bud?
-I did it.
-Oh, you're doing it?
-Yeah.
-Oh, no.
Can you go really slow?
-I like...
-To move it, move it.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-[ Laughter ]
-I like...
-...to...
-To push it?
Sorry. I don't --
-To move it.
-I like to move it!
-Yes!
-♪ I like to move it, move it ♪
-Listen to the beat.
I had that same beat!
That's so weird. I was like --
That was so weird.
Hailee Steinfeld, everybody.
"Hawkeye" premieres
on Disney Plus tomorrow.